Good afternoon.
I am Lillian Siu. I'm the immediate past president of AACR as
of a few hours ago. Welcome.
You can see I'm very happy because
I think the meeting has been very successful, and I can actually enjoy the meeting
now. Welcome to the AACR/ASCO joint session.
It is my great pleasure to co-chair this with my colleague, ASCO
president, Dr. Eric Small, and our topic is exciting.
That's why you're here at this hour of the day.
This is next generation CAR T cell therapies.
We're going to hear from three fantastic speakers on
this area of treatment in both solid malignancies
and hematological malignancies, and what's new and exciting about
this field of research. So before we invite the speakers, I'm going to get
Dr. Small to make some opening remarks. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dr. Siu. It's a real pleasure to be here, and
it's been an amazing meeting, and to be here representing ASCO.
I was just reflecting,
in a month or two, I'll be chairing some of the
sessions at the annual meeting in ASCO, and the main difference will be at that
meeting, I'll be wearing the same suit, but I'll have a tie on.
In this meeting,
I can go tieless, which is great.
It's really, really been wonderful to co-develop this session
between ASCO and AACR. I think Nancy Davidson is in the room here
who takes credit, I think rightly so, for establishing the idea of
this joint meeting between our two wonderful societies.
So thank you for that, Dr. Davidson.
I also want to point out that at the ASCO annual meeting coming up in
Chicago, there is a shared joint session between
AACR and ASCO, which will be focusing on the KRAS
journey, which we've already heard a lot about at this meeting.
So we're looking forward to that.
Super excited with this session. Just some spectacular speakers,
and we're just going to jump right into it.
Our first speaker then is speaking towards
in vivo CAR Ts, Dr. Saar Gill, University of Pennsylvania.
Dr. Gill.
Okay. Thanks very much for inviting me.
Look forward to sharing with you a little bit of our thoughts
about a rapidly moving field.
I'm actually not going to show that much data from my own group because this is
a brand new, exciting field with some
exciting developments daily hitting the airwaves.
And so,
I'll go straight into it.
I
don't really have any relevant financial disclosures.
did co-found a company,
in the in vivo CAR T space, but it's been acquired now, and I have no idea what's
going on with it, and so I clearly have no disclosures.
So let me describe the current ex vivo versus the near
future, or actually now, in vivo CAR T platforms
and paradigms.
You're all pretty familiar, I'm sure, with how ex vivo CAR T works.
It is
really a testament to biopharma
industry's logistic ability and
capacity that this really complicated
chain of events occurs all the time actually in our institutions
and works so successfully. But it is
complex. It is expensive. It is
still associated with logistical hurdles.
And so what we and others are shooting for is what's at the
bottom here, which is the in vivo CAR T world.
So in this world, the drug is more akin to gene therapy.
And actually, the main thrust of the first part of the talk is going to be to
explain to you at least my view on how gene therapy diverged from cell therapy and
how it's now reconverging.
So the drug essentially is your particles.
They could be lipid nanoparticles, or they could be
viral-like particles, what I like to call nature's lipid nanoparticles.
And then in the former case, typically the LNPs will deliver mRNA for
transient expression, and in the latter case, at the bottom of the slide, the
targeted viral vector will deliver typically,
basically the antiviral integration.
And so the idea, the dream, I suppose, when people started working
on this some years ago, was that as
a physician, you'd be able to write a prescription for your CAR
viral gene therapy or non-viral gene therapy.
The patient would get an IV inserted, and then up from pharmacy would come maybe
a lyophilized vial or a frozen vial of vector, which
would be injected intravenously, and the patient would
get CAR T cells manufactured in their own organs, their own lymphoid organs
being the bioreactor that otherwise would be your GMP facility.
And so that's really the idea. And implicit within that,
something that I'll address now but won't go into in detail
later, is that lymphodepleting chemotherapy is simply
inconsistent, not compatible with this approach, because if you lymphodeplete,
you won't have any T-cells to transduce.
And yet that was a paradox that really bothered me for a while until we
saw that there was clinical activity in the field, which is we believe
that lymphodepleting chemotherapy is necessary for the function of CAR
T adoptive cell therapy, so how is this ever going to work?
So in my view, at least, how
did cell therapy diverge from gene therapy?
In the following ways. So firstly, the issue of efficacy.
Okay, so quantity versus quality.
Then we'll talk about biology and then about safety.So efficacy
considerations, quantity or quality?
If you look at the bottom first, it's very clear to us, all of you who have done
these experiments in the lab yourself or made cells,
cell number increases with the length of ex vivo expansion. Of course.
And it used to be thought that the more cells you infuse, the better.
That is clearly not the case. And in fact, it has become pretty clear that the
per cell potency decreases with the length or
duration of ex vivo manipulation.
And this is supported by some selected preclinical
citations that I have, as well as increasingly from clinical trials, none of which,
of course, are head-to-head. But the thrust of it, nonetheless, is that as you
infuse cells that have been less manipulated ex vivo, going from what used to be
the standard of three weeks of ex vivo expansion to
nine days of ex vivo expansion, to two or three days of ex vivo
expansion, maybe zero days of ex vivo expansion, which is really what we're
talking about, would give you the best quality of cells.
So can non-activated T cells be lentivirally transduced?
Okay, so you've got your resting T cell on the left and your activated T cell on
the bottom. There's no doubt that activated T cells are much more receptive to
lentiviral transduction. And I'm going to focus most of my remarks on
lentiviral transduction because that's what I work on.
So what are the problems, and what were the reasons why people did
not think that this would work?
The first one, let's call it a gate, would be entry.
So the cell surface receptor for the-- typically, we pseudotyped a
viral-like particles with the VSV glycoprotein.
The receptor of which was identified about 10 years ago as being
the LDL receptor.
And it is expressed at very low levels on resting cells and is very significantly
upregulated on T cells when you activate them.
And so
since the LDLR is low or absent, the assumption was that VSVG
could not dock. And indeed, that is correct when you use your
standard VSVG pseudotyping strategy.
And there's another aspect which remains actually
unaddressed, and this I suspect will be
a focus of significant investigation in the coming years, which
is that
successful reverse transcription requires a considerable
dNTP pool, which is low in resting T cells, as it is in
other difficult-to-transduce cell types.
Comparatively, on the right side of the slide, with activated T cells, both those
problems are solved. There is an upregulation of the LDL receptor, and then there's
also an increase in the dNTP pool, partly related to phosphorylation
of the restriction factor SAM HD1.
What about specificity? So is it a crazy idea to
inject lentiviral vectors into a human being?
Could they possibly be specific? Well, I posit
that actually the system is exquisitely specific.
If you think about HIV, well, we know very
well that HIV cannot infect cells that lack CD4 or
one of its co-receptor, CXCR4 or CCR5.
So clearly, the system is exquisitely specific.
And as I mentioned to you, in the case of-- we don't use the standard pseudotyping
if you like. We use typically VSVG pseudotyping or a related one called
cocal. And so there the receptor is I think
known. So what about safety? What about insertional mutagenesis?
If you did all of what I mentioned, and you could transduce cells in vivo, and it
was safe to inject a lentiviral vector intravenously,
would you
cause insertional mutagenesis? Don't CAR T cells cause T cell malignancies?
Well, I think very rarely. So less than 0.1% of the
time, if that. More than 35,000 people have been treated
with CAR T cells all over the world, and the
number of bona fide cases of actual insertional mutagenesis
is very, very low. Not only that, but there actually are some
instances, at least one most famous one that came from our institution
from quite a long time ago now, which actually showed that a single T
cell, a single CAR T cell, could expand and reject CLL in a patient.
That's the top citation there. And that was related to
insertional activ-- essentially disruption
leading to a biallelic disruption of the gene TED2.
It didn't cause cancer, but it did confer upon that
particular T cell in which this happened quite
expansive properties.
And so the basic requirements for a safe and effective in vivo transduction
platform are, number one, a sufficient number of high-quality cells.
What's a sufficient number? We'll talk about that in a minute.
Biology, you need non-dividing T cells that are receptive to genetic
modification. A little footnote there.
In my or your body right at the moment, even though we're not in the midst
of an infection or a viral infection or possibly autoimmune disease, not all of
our T cells are non-dividing. Some of them are.
And so it isn't entirely true that these are completely non-dividing T cells.
And with respect to safety, we want to accomplish specific delivery of our
transgene to the candidate cell, and you could do that using--
well, I'll show you in a second how you could engineer the viral membrane,
the pseudotyping,
and/or, either or both of those
factors achieve specific expression of a transgene within the candidate cell, for
example, a lineage-restricted transcription factor.
Okay, so a sufficient number of high-quality cells.
So the number-- and we did this back of the envelope calculation a while ago.
The number of axicell
cells that are infused is two by 10 to the eighth CAR T cells.
What number of
T cells in the body would you have to transduce?
So what percentage of the T cells in a body of an
adult human would you have to transduce to get to that number?
Well, assuming some very large assumptions, healthy human blood,
10 by 10 to the nine T cells, you need a 2% transduction efficiency.
If you challenge yourself a little bit more and you say, "Okay, this is not a
healthy donor. This is a patient who's a little bit lymphopenic." One by 10 to the
nine T cells, 20%, but that's in the blood, okay?
It is possible, though not yet provenThat when you do this
approach, be it viral or non-viral approach, you may
have access to all the T cells in the patient's body, not just the ones that are
circulating in the blood. And there you're potentially dealing with two orders of
magnitude more than that. And so conceivably, you only need something like a
.05% transduction efficiency at baseline to reach 200
million
CAR-positive cells, notwithstanding the fact that we know that T cells are
capable of extensive in vivo proliferation.
So where are these cells? Well, this is a nice figure.
This is mostly speculative, by calculation and
with some extrapolations, but basically showing you that actually, most
of the T cells in your body aren't in the circulating compartment. Okay?
They're in the lymphoid organs, in the spleen, in the bone
marrow. So this leads to an open question, which I like to still put up there
because it's still open and I would love people to investigate this
because it's an interesting point.
We may have access to T cells that are not blood T cells, but rather in other
organs. And so there is a possibility that tissue-resident immune effector cells,
AKA T cells, may be better suited to undertake cancer immunotherapy than those in
the blood, since we now maybe can access them.
So what about specific delivery and also the permanence versus transience
of this approach? So, here is a
simple table. You've got your viral approaches, permanent, like
integrating viruses like lenti or transient,
such as episomal viruses like
AAV or non-viral approaches, which may be transient on the bottom right, such
as mRNA delivery or potentially permanent, as has been
published, a very beautiful paper recently,
by Justin Akem's group,
with a CRISPR cut and paste approach.
So all of these are possible. I'm going to talk very
briefly about vectorology. This is just to show you the scope of what we can talk
about, but we're actually going to zero in on the
mechanics of targeted lentiviral vector, and how the system
works clinically now. So on the top, you've got your
VLP,
and
this is one in which the VSV glycoprotein has been blinded
by insertion of several mutations that I'll detail for you in a moment, such that
it is no longer able to bind the LDL receptor, which after all is
very
frequently expressed on cells in the body.
So those viral particles are now blinded, and then in order to confer specificity
for whatever you want, let's say a T cell marker such as CD3, you
decorate the viral-like protein, the VLP
membrane with an anti-CD3 scFv or an
anti-CD7 scFv or any other marker for a T cell marker of
interest. And then within it, of course, you've got your
transgene. And then what happens is that there is binding
of the, let's say, the molecule, we think, but are not sure.
We think that the molecules should be ones that internalize upon
binding as CD3 does, as the TCR complex does, in order to then
enhance the endocytosis and then
endosome, followed by endosomal escape, which
requires falling of the pH and then reverse transcription to occur.
That's how it works.
Focusing on vesicular viruses such as VSVG, I mentioned to you before, and I'll
show in this slide and in the subsequent slide, that others have
identified several mutations that abolish recognition of the
glycoprotein
for the LDL receptor. And that's a feature of safety,
mostly, I think, in order to prevent the injection of
un-redirected lentiviral vector into the patient, which would transduce each and
every cell, quite possibly. And so the idea then is you blind it, then you
re-confer specificity with a binder of interest, which could be an scFv
or a DARPIn or anything else.
So, here's an example. You've got your LDLR-positive cell, which can be
infected. Resting T cells generally cannot. Activated T cells can.
This is with the wild type VSVG that we all use in our labs.
Introduction of some of those mutations that I showed you means that none of those
cells can be transduced. But then with the targeting ligands, you can target them
to whatever you want. And it ends up being really quite specific.
And I'll show you a brief example of that in two slides.
So I mentioned that there is a company, I'm no longer connected to that company,
but I did co-found it, and that is shown here simply as an
example of a drug. This drug, if you like, is
a anti-CD20 CAR-bearing viral-like particle
concoction where those VLPs are redirected to CD7, which is
on most T cells and in K cells. And there are
several mutations that were introduced into that to induce serum stability,
complement resistance, and de-targeting for the LDLR.
And then, as I mentioned, an anti-CD7 scFv on the
VLPs. And what you can see here, we've got on the top row,
GFP versus CD8, GFP versus CD4. On the bottom, GFP is the
reporter transgene in this instance.
And you can see that with standard VSVG, of course, you get
nonspecific GFP transduction. No binder.
It's very clean. And then with the CD7 binder, you can see
both CD8 and CD4 cells express CD7. So that doesn't look like it's specific.
But if you use a CD8-specific scFv, you can see that it's very
clean. Only CD8 cells are transduced. And on the bottom row is an example.
You can use one of three different reagents specific to human CD4, an
scFv, a camelid-based VHH or a DARPIn, and you can see it's
very nicely specific.
So some preclinical data.
These are monkeys that were
injected once intravenously with VLPs redirected against
CD7 with the same reagents. So
there's cross-reactivity between non-human primates and humans for the
CD7 and also for the CAR 20. So this is, of course, CD20 being
largely cross-reactive between monkeys and human.
In these two examples that I'm showing you, a control where
there's no change in B cells in the blood, and ultimately at
necropsy, you see B-cell follicles in the spleen of the animal compared to an
animal on the right that receivedCAR20, and you can see that there
is B-cell aplasia that is persistent.
And I'll skip through this, but the point of this particular figure is to show you
that in the spleen and also in the liver and the lung of the
animal, there was CAR20 expressed on T cells and NK cells, but not
on epithelial cells. And this is a little too busy to look at, so you'll have to
take my word for it. Ultimately, however, a lot of the animals had
developed anti-CAR antibodies detected by 7 to 14 days.
This was very immunogenic. This was a wholly human construct that was injected
into monkeys. You might imagine what would happen if you injected a whole
monkey
reagent into a human. So with the development of anti-CAR antibodies, there
was B-cell aplasia. The B-cells came back,
basically. In the last few slides, I want to share with you some really exciting
results from other entities. So this was recently published
by a company that was
subsequently purchased. This was a clinical trial done in China with in vivo
generation of CAR T cells directed against BCMA.
Same system that I explained to you in depth with some notable additions
here. The VLPs were redirected towards the TCR rather than
CD7. There was also CD47 overexpression
on the producer cell lines in order to
reduce the ability of phagocytic cells to uptake these particles and knock out of
MHC class I. And there was also a T-cell-specific synthetic promoter in order
to, I guess again, enhance safety.
This was remarkably efficacious.
So the original publication from about a year ago detailed, I think, four patients.
This publication from a few weeks ago detailed
those plus another patient,
showing that
while one patient had an early death,
at least to me, the reason wasn't clear, but the other patients had either a
stringent complete response or a very good partial response, which are
typically what you look for in multiple myeloma, and notably were MID negative,
and you can see that at day 60 with those red triangles.
This was associated with a, in my view,
remarkably consistent pharmacokinetic and toxicity profile like you
might see with Cilta-Cel, for example.
There was quite considerable expansion both by qPCR on the left
and by flow cytometry on the right in the blood of all these patients, with a peak
of around 12 to 14, so maybe a little bit later than with the ex vivo CAR T, but
nonetheless, the magnitude seemed to me to be quite similar.
With regard to safety, five out of five patients had a grade 3 adverse
event, which was three out of three patients had a grade 3
CRS, one had a grade 2. All were treated with tocilizumab, if I'm not
mistaken, and one patient had a grade 1 ICANS.
The purpose of the figures here is to show you each panel is
cytokine in all the patients, and it shows you that there is a bimodal
toxicity. There was a profile, there was initially an infusion
reaction,
and secondarily to that, there was the reaction that you see with cytokine release
syndrome. Then this other, this is, I think, not yet published, but was presented
publicly at ASH in December of last year.
This is another anti-BCMA CAR viral-like particle by another
company, presented by Joey Ho at
ASH, and again, showing really nice expansion of the CAR T cells
without lymphodepleting chemotherapy on the left.
You can see that the CAR is abundantly expressed on T cells in the
blood at day 15.
That's shown on the right,
and that there were deep and ongoing MRD negative responses in the first four
patients shown, which was really, I think, really exciting.
And all the CRS events were grade one to two in this
instance. The last clinical bit of data that I want to
show you is actually from lipid nanoparticles
encapsulating mRNA that encodes an anti-CD19
CAR, and this was actually in lupus.
So you all know, I think, very well that autoimmune patients are sometimes treated
with CART19, and this is exactly what was done here.
The dosing is repetitive, as it has to be with mRNA-LNP because
those cells don't proliferate very much.
And then what was shown is that there was CAR T cells were detected in the
blood, that's shown on the top left, that there was B-cell aplasia achieved
in these patients for about a month or so, maybe
two months, shown on the right.
Each infusion was associated with some cytokine release syndrome.
I'm showing you fever rather than cytokines at the bottom here.
So that's a feature of CRS, of course.
And then I am less familiar with reading the sort of response
criteria in SLE, but what I gather from this is that the
score, so higher on the score is greater severity of this
autoimmune disease, SLE. And in some patients, it looked like there was a, maybe
not in patient one, but certainly in the other patients, there was a reduction in
the, I think it's the SLEDAI score, which is a severity score for SLE.
So my last slide is here. The current standard
ex vivo versus the upcoming in vivo platform, and I think this is what I'd like to
convey as the takeaway in terms of thinking about this.
So of course, and these are obvious statements, I think, but nonetheless, to
synthesize what I've said. The drug is cells, but on the right
side, the drug is particles, be they VLPs or LNPs.
The cells that are modified on the left are those that are removed from the blood,
and that's all the cells that you have access to, for better or for worse.
Whereas with the in vivo approaches, you have access to cells in the blood, but
quite possibly in other compartments in the body, but that's to be shown.
The dosing is based, well, we know what the dosing is based with ex vivo.
It's a number of CAR-positive cells, which you know what they are from
manufacturing.
In contrast with in vivo approaches, it's transducing units or number
of LNPs or dose of mRNA.
And so we need to start thinking in a slightly different way about this.
Expansion occurs in vivo, yes. With ex vivo, yes.
With in vivo from the VLPs, I showed you that data.
Not really, I think, with the mRNA LNPs.
Lymphodepletion is required with the ex vivo and is
not compatible with the in vivo approach, and that obviously has its own
advantages.The PK and biodistribution are, I think,
pretty well known with ex vivo but are not known particularly well with the in vivo
approaches yet. The toxicity is known, and actually, I would
say
now with very recent data, I think we're starting to get a good sense of what the
toxicity of in vivo approaches is as well, and appears
remarkably similar, though, of course, you don't have the toxicity of the
lymphodepleting chemotherapy.
The risk of off-target genetic modification with ex vivo, when I say no, I
mean,
of course, ex vivo, are the cells in the apheresis product, but not in the
tissues of the patient. And it is theoretically possible for that
to happen in vivo with the lenti approaches.
And then immunogenicity of CARs, maybe.
Probably not with B-cell-specific CARs, maybe because we get rid of our
B cells. But it is possible with in vivo CARs, and I
showed you some data, at least from animals.
So that's really all I wanted to say, and I don't actually have a disclosure slide.
This was mostly a review of our and other people's work, but thank you very much
for your time.
Thank you so much. We have time for just a couple of questions.
If there are some, please come to the mics either side of the room.
Thank you so much, Dr. Saar. I have a question.
My question is, when do you think it's time to
support funding the biological-based
delivery platform, like
bioengineered CAR-like exosome platform that you
already developed in your CCR department?
Not just as a replacement for targeted LNP
or targeted lentiviral particle, as a product in
parallel, as a comparison to see which one would be more
beneficial in 10 years in future.
Sorry, so you're asking me about
exosomes in particular?
Bioengineered exosomes, yeah.
Bioengineered exosomes. I don't know.
Not my area of expertise, but I suppose I would say that if there's strong
biological rationale, then the time is now, probably.
Of course. As we presented to you, this new
technology needs
funding support.
Well, if I had the funding, I would give it to you.
Okay. Thank you so much. Thank you.
So I wanted to follow up and stress the safety concerns a little
bit more. I'm fully supportive. I think this is a great area.
But from the trial you mentioned in China, where five out of
five patients get grade 3 or more AEs and one
out of five patients dying from some sort of toxicity
that was
maybe inflammatory and cardiac-related.
That's a pretty high number. So, giving 10 to the
ninth viral particles is going to be very inflammatory,
and how is that going to be parsed to get
enough vector and not so much inflammation?
Yeah. Thanks for that question. I think
it's an assumption that the early toxicity was
related to an innate immune response to an infusional
reaction to the viral particles. It's possible.
You might say that there should be a profound inflammatory response to the infusion
of two by 10 to the eighth CAR-positive cells into a
patient, and
there isn't, right? There's CRS-
So they're getting lymphodepletion.
I'm sorry?
That's with lymphodepletion.
Maybe. But I think that
you might be right. I think it's entirely possible.
But there's also the possibility, and this is, I suppose,
my bias.
When you cross-link CD3, as both of those products did,
and particularly the
case you're talking about, the viral-like particles clearly
cross-link CD3. And that's probably why there's such good activation
and
proliferation of those cells.
We know what happens when you cross-link CD3 in a dish, and there's also a drug
that does that in patients. It causes this toxicity.
So we don't know, I think, which one of those reactions it is.
Okay.
But to the larger point that I think you're making, absolutely.
Well, let me take half a step back, which is when I saw that
data, I thought, "This is not as safe as I was expecting it to be."
Right.
And I think maybe on that, we agree.
You approach a half measure of
lymphodepletion. Maybe a little.
Is that possible? You need the cells,
but is there some way to attenuate
that?
I think first we should find out what the cause-- And again, I'll
tell you,
well, not through published observations, but that
means of transducing cells that
are not based on
CD3 cross-linking
do not cause this toxicity.
Okay. Very good. Thank you.
There
has to be some context placed. The lupus patients that
they are studying are sicker than sick.
They fail just about every therapy, and they are on a deathbed.
So this is dramatic.
Yes. No, I think I agree with you that the
responses
to CAR T-cells in autoimmune disease are dramatic and very exciting.
Yeah. They're not studying routine lupus patients.
These are patients that have basically failed every therapy.
Sure. No.
Every immunosuppressant you want to put on them.
Yeah. Totally agree.
A quick one. I really
like your comment about the fact that we will be able to gain access to T-cell
populations we do not have with ex vivo CAR.
So I'm looking for your perspective on whether we can break that
glass ceiling with solid tumor indications now that we will be able to reach
TLs and TRMs and a bunch of other T-cells that work well or
better in solid tumor indications.
I think it's entirely possible, and I think that's a really-...
exciting
prospect of the near future is now that we know this works in a small
number of patients, but in contexts where ex vivo CAR T cells
do work, of course, that's where you're going to start.
But I think now everyone should start
working on this in solid tumors. Yeah.
Thank you.
One last quick question.
Thank you very much, Dr. Gale. It's really great to see you here again.
You mentioned before in the Tandem conference about your HSC-derived cell
therapies for ex vivo, and this time you mentioned about your in vivo CAR T cell
therapies.
From your vision, what are the differences and what are the modalities that can be
really treated for different disease areas in the future?
And would you see those growing in parallel or one replacing the other?
I would love to answer that, but that's not a quick
one, so maybe we can chat afterwards.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, great. That may be a good panel question.
Our next speaker is Dr. Crystal Mackall from Stanford
University, and Crystal is going to talk to us about CAR T cells
for pediatric brain tumors.
Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you, Drs.
Lu and Small,
for the invitation. Pleasure to be here.
Here are my disclosures. So I'm going to talk to you today about the efforts
that we have underway to develop CAR T cells for a lethal
pediatric brain tumor.
It also actually occurs in adults, but it's well-known for
afflicting school-aged children.
And you can see there that the median overall survival is dismal.
Essentially, no patients survive this tumor.
And we know a lot about its biology.
It's driven by a mutation in the H3 histone
that leads to widespread transcriptional
dysregulation. And it turns out that this
H3 histone axis is the axis that controls
production of gangliosides. And as a
result, these tumors massively overexpress
the fatty sugar GD2, the so-called disialo
ganglioside, really at levels in the
millions of molecules per cell.
And just for context, CD19 is
expressed at about 50,000 molecules per cell on B cells.
So it's really massively overexpressed.
Michel Mange's lab made this discovery back in 2017,
and we began collaborating because we had been working on developing a CAR T cell
targeting GD2. And
try as we might to develop new binders to this fatty sugar,
we haven't been able to. And so we've been stuck with this
mouse-derived anti-GD2 single-chain Fv that was
developed in the 1980s. Nonetheless, this
GD2 CAR, after intravenous infusion in neonatal
mice that are implanted with these tumors in their midbrain,
cured these mice with one intravenous infusion.
And we also studied the efficacy of
intracerebroventricular CAR T cells in the setting
of this and other brain tumors. And what we learned is that both worked,
but intracerebroventricular delivery was more potent.
And in fact, we needed about tenfold less T cells if we were
delivering them directly into the brain.
And even when we directly infused them into the brain, they
did traffic to the periphery and often were sustained.
And this is a teaser for what I'm going to talk about today, but you can see
several months out in these mice, you still find these T cells
circulating. So we had the opportunity now to translate this by
either administering CAR T cells intravenously into these
children or intracerebroventricularly or
intracranially. And so we decided to hedge our bets on the
first rollout of this trial, so-called Arm A.
And basically, patients were required to have the mutation.
They had an Ommaya reservoir placed, which is the catheter that allows
us to administer these cells into the brain.
And the first infusion was intravenous after standard lymphodepletion.
If the patient did well and showed some evidence of benefit, they could
receive sequential intracerebroventricular infusions, and we
didn't give additional lymphodepletion before those.
And you can see the team that worked together to get this trial launched.
Now, the results from Arm A were published a few years ago,
and overall, there was clear evidence for clinical activity.
Thirteen patients were enrolled, and 11 were treated.
And we saw significant numbers of patients with major tumor shrinkage.
Now, for this disease, where there is no standard upfront therapy
besides palliative radiotherapy, to see this type of
regressions was really quite notable.
The median overall survival typically for this disease is nine to 11
months, and we saw a very favorable median overall survival
despite the caveats of a single-arm trial.
And perhaps most gratifying, we saw substantial clinical
benefit in many patients. And in particular, this was the
patient number 10. He was 17 when he was enrolled, and he's
achieved a complete response that's been ongoing for over
four years from enrollment. And when he came to us, he
was able to walk, but really not very far, and used a
wheelchair for any distance and had stopped going to high school because
he was homebound. And so here he is one month after his first
infusion. You can see his father has to help him walk
because he's had so much neurologic compromise.
Eight months after the first infusion, he's obviously walking on his own,
and he subsequently went on to go away to college and complete his
degree and travel Europe and do all the normal things.
So the good news is we did have clinical activity.
The bad news is, as it's often in cancer medicine, we saw some
significant toxicity. One of the major
toxicities was high-grade cytokine release syndrome
after the intravenous infusion. You can see there.
We did not see cytokine release syndrome after the subsequent
intracerebroventricular infusion.We did
define a new toxicity, so-called tumor
inflammation-associated neurotoxicity, and this is related to swelling of
the tumor that leads to neurologic compromise or increased intracranial
pressure. This was not dose-limiting and could be managed with careful
monitoring and treatment algorithms.
Now, one of the clues that we uncovered as we looked at the correlative
results in the patients treated on arm A, were that the patients who tended to
do better tended to have more prolonged persistence of the GD2 CAR in their
bloodstream. This is patient 10, our durable responder,
and his CAR T cells were circulating for over a year.
Here's patient number six, who had good levels in her bloodstream for the first
three months, but then subsequently relapsed, and you can see her cell-free
DNA recurring about the time her CAR Ts disappear.
So this gave us a hint that persistence mattered.
All right. So at this point, we had favorable survival, but this
dose-limiting cytokine release syndrome.
So we modified the trial, and we said, "Let's get rid of the intravenous
infusion, and let's put the cells where the tumor
is." And so we gave them intracerebroventricularly,
without any previous lymphodepletion and without any
intravenous infusion. And unfortunately, the results
were not as good. Patients had transient responses, but they would
rarely last longer than two to three months.
And while the cytokine release syndrome was gone, we really felt
we had lost our efficacy. And when you look at the persistence of
patients in the bloodstream, all of the patients enrolled on arm A, you see
we had this very nice persistence of the GD2 CAR T cells, but
very poor persistence, really, in the bloodstream or even in the
CNS of patients enrolled on arm B, where we took the
lymphodepletion away. And so this led us to think that
perhaps immune responses to the CAR T cells were limiting
CAR T cell persistence in arm B and preventing
disease control. And maybe the lymphodepletion we gave on arm
A
prevented these immune rejection.
So we went looking for these immune responses, and the first thing we did was a
cell-based assay looking for circulating
anti-CAR antibodies, an old-fashioned assay.
We expressed GD2 CAR on the surface of a T cell.
We come in with patient serum or a control
anti-idiotype, and then we do a sandwich assay looking for the presence
of cell-bound antibody. And indeed, we found them in
most patients, and the level of these anti-CAR antibodies
in the plasma was inversely related to the persistence of the CAR
T cells, consistent with our hypothesis.
When you take the serum from these patients in the presence of these anti-CAR
antibodies and you incubate it at the time you
inoculate CAR T cells with these tumor cells, you see that
the serum interferes with killing.
Look at the dashed lines compared to the solid lines for each of
the various dilutions. So these antibodies
were directly capable of impeding CAR killing.
And in several cases, we noted that the onset of the
antibodies temporally correlated with loss of
circulating GD2 CAR T cells. Look at patient number six here.
Here are the circulating GD2 CAR T cells.
About the time the human anti-CAR antibodies appear in the serum,
we see the CAR T cells disappear. This is the clinical result.
This patient had a response in green, and then soon after that, had
progression. Here's patient number nine, who had very good
persistence of his CAR T cells until the onset of the anti-CAR
antibodies in the blood, ultimately followed by relapse.
Now, we have an extensive single-cell atlas that's been
interrogated by Yuyun Chen, who's in the audience and will be presenting her poster
tomorrow, number 6463. I encourage folks who are
interested to look at it. But this is providing us with immense
information about the immune responses that are happening in the
CNS of these patients treated with CAR T cells.
So
overall, when you step back and you say, "What is in the
CSF of these patients after each cycle?" And
these are their mean levels.
You can see that the hatched marks here are the CAR T cells.
The orange hatch is CD4 CARs, and the blue hatch are
CD8 CARs. And you see they don't make up much of the cells in the
CSF, and they're really only present in any significant
quantity during the early cycles.
By the time you get to the later cycles, you find almost no CAR T
cells in the CNS, even though we're administering them about once a
month. If you look at non-CAR T cells, those are the blue and the
orange, there are plenty of non-CAR T cells in that CNS.
And if you look at the clonality using single-cell
TCR-seq, you see that the CAR T
cells in the CNS that are present are not clonally
expanded. Whereas the CAR-negative cells, presumably
derived from endogenous T cells, show significant
clonal expansion. Here's another way of looking at this.
The CAR-negative cells here, now we're following the top 20
clonotypes in these CAR-negative T cells.
And you can see that once these clonotypes show up, they
largely persist over time. And sometimes during these late
time points associated with disease progression, they increase, both
in patient six and patient nine. But look at the CAR positive T
cells. They come in, and they disappear, and they are not sustained.
Here's our patient number 10, our complete responder.
He's got an onset of these CAR-negative cells in his
CNS, but they eventually get
diminished. In fact, they did not sustain over time,
really suggesting to us that these CAR-negative T cells that are clonally
expanding in the CNS may bePlaying a
part in the rejection. So Max Koch from the
Heisenator Lab
really went to look for the anti-CAR T cell responses, and
he found them broadly. These are CD4 anti-CAR T
cell responses making IL-2 and interferon gamma.
You can see very clearly these are quite robust, and this is the population as
a whole showing high levels of anti-CAR T cell responses.
Here are the CD8 responses,
degranulating and upregulating 4-1BB.
Again, very high levels of anti-CAR T cell responses.
Using an overlapping peptide library, Max was able to map these
responses. And not surprisingly, they mapped in large
part to the mouse-derived single-chain Fv from the old
antibody from which we made the CAR.
They also mapped to the junctional domains, where you create a
non-native protein where 4-1BB and
zeta, for instance, overlap. But in some cases, they actually overlapped
on fully human components like Icaspase-9.
So these patients are generating robust
CD4, CD8, and anti-CAR antibody
responses in the blood. Now let's go back to the
CSF and look for B cells in the CSF. And indeed, you see them
show up in some patients, usually associated at the time of
progression and increasing with time.
And in general, the more B cells that you found in the CSF, the
worse the patient did on those cycles. It was trended that way.
Now, were the B cells in the CNS actually producing anti-CAR
antibodies? Now again, we take those top 10
clonotypes,
and we now express those genes in
a line that's capable of producing antibodies, and then we check to see, does the
antibody bind the CAR expressing T cells?
And you can see indeed, most of the top
clonotypes found in the CNS actually bind
cell-associated GD2 CAR. Now, for those of us that aren't
CNS immunobiologists, and I don't think very few of us are, it turns
out that most of these were of the IgA isotype.
And this surprised us because generally, we think of early
antibodies in the circulation, et cetera, being IgG, but many of
these were IgA, and it turns out that meningeal lymphatics
are enriched with
IgA-producing B cells, which have
evidently been educated in the gut.
And so we think this provides very strong evidence that
some of these anti-CAR antibody responses are actually being produced
within the CNS, not just in the periphery.
Okay, so here we are. What do we do now?
We realize that we've backed off on the lymphodepletion, and now we've lost our
response. So we added lymphodepletion back.
Now we're administering ICV only and giving lymphodepletion
about every four cycles. And now we start to see very
durable responses, and you can see our current
data from this trial, which is ongoing.
Arm C is the arm where we're giving intracerebroventricular CAR
T cells only with lymphodepletion approximately every four
cycles. We've now added rituximab on another arm,
Arm D, and it's too early to present that data.
But for this disease, for which there really has never been any therapy
that could lead to durable responses, we're quite
excited about these results on Arm C.
So GD2 CAR T cells induce impressive responses associated with
prolonged survival in diffuse midline gliomas.
The resistance that we've found in this setting is associated with anti-CAR
immune responses, both in the CSF and the periphery.
These results align with our emerging understanding of neuroimmunology.
We've talked about the CNS as immune privileged, but in fact, there is
significant crosstalk between the CNS and the peripheral immune system.
And the bias we talked about toward IgA antibodies suggests that
some of this response, at least, is likely initiated in
the CNS or in the peri-CNS tissues.
Now, this means that lymphodepletion, even though we'd like to get rid of it,
it's a critical component of a successful CAR T cell regimen in this
setting, and this may generalize to other brain tumors.
I think we've all heard that causes for
limited CAR T cell responses in solid tumors relate to
problems like T cell exhaustion, suppressive microenvironment, but I
think we need to add immunogenicity to this list.
And we all know that stealth platforms were developed for allogeneic CAR T
cells. These data suggest that perhaps we should be using stealth platforms
in the context of auto-CAR T cells in solid tumors.
And then finally, this is a negative for these patients.
But when you see this consistent breadth and very
strong immune response that's induced by CAR T cells, it
raises the prospect that we could exploit this by
co-delivering CAR T cells with a regimen optimized for
vaccinating against the tumor antigen.
And so I think that's something that should be considered.
So this has taken really a very large team.
I want to highlight the work of Michel Mange, who I've done all of this work very
closely hand in hand with, Kunwei Song, Jasi Amade, other
neuro-oncologists, our pediatric cancer cell therapist, Neha Ramakrishna,
has played a leading role in the correlative science, as well as Bita Sahaf, our
collaborators, Sabine, Zena, Max Koch, Elena,
Yeyun Chen, who led the single-cell RNA-seq, and Kevin Reynolds, who really
led the work on the antibodies. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Crystal. We have time for a couple of
quick questions. If there are any, please come up to the
microphone.
I think one over there.
Please go ahead.
Thank you. That was a very interesting talk.
I have this general question.
So these
CAR T cells are given repeatedly, and in
this kind of approach, do you make one big batch
of CAR T cells and give from that batch?
And then
if that's the case, what would happen to change that
approach and every time get fresh CAR T, because CAR T
cells are depleted,
and considering this evolution of T cell modality and
everything, would it impact?
Yeah. We can get about eight doses or so
per manufacturing run. So we sometimes can
make multiple runs from one apheresis.
Occasionally, we'll do a second apheresis.
But I think it's been relatively straightforward to do that in this
population, which is not lymphodepleted.
Okay. I think I'll alternate. Go ahead.
Thank you for the beautiful talk. I was wondering whether you want to
completely replace the lymph depletion by rituximab or only the
later cycles of lymph depletion?
Oh, I should have stated. We are giving Cyflu approximately every
fourth cycle. And on RMD, we've added
rituximab-
In addition
... with Cyflu, because our goal is to prevent the antibodies
from coming up.
And what do you think about the Carl June approach, that you also add a little bit
of CD19 CAR?
Well, people talk about that. It's just not
economical. I'm going to have a hard enough time developing this for a
rare pediatric indication with one CAR.
So-
Thanks for that
... if rituximab does it, we're going to stick with that.
Thank you.
Thank you. Go ahead.
Hi. Thanks for a great talk. Ben from Mass General.
I am wondering about what you think the mechanism of the inhibition
of CAR T killing is when the antibodies appear.
Is it inhibition of that binding to the target?
Is it ADCP? Is it trogocytosis?
Yeah. We haven't done our ADCP analysis.
I think there could be some increased clearance, but what that assay is showing
is it's just interfering with the ability of the CAR to engage its antigen.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Hi. Great talk. Crystal Nickason from UCLA.
For the patients that were on RMD that weren't lymphodepleted but then didn't
respond, did you try lymphodepleting later or doing some other
therapy to see if they could regain response?
We didn't. We didn't catch on to this until too late.
And so we're really very sad about that. We didn't have the correlative data.
And so no, we just didn't have the opportunity to do it.
Back to you.
Hi. I'm Anne Marie. I'm in CCSU with you.
So I was just wondering, so you showed some initial strong
responses, but then obviously, there's some resistance.
What would you say would make a promising way to make the
therapy work better for longer for these patients?
Yeah. Well, we're excited about the lymphodepletion because to see
a median not reached and about leveling
off at over 50%, it's really quite remarkable.
But you raise a good point. It's not the whole story.
And there's another axis of resistance that's likely related to the
myeloid cells in the CNS that are also
contributing. And there may be more. And so stay tuned.
We'll be putting that myeloid story together.
Okay. And then just a quick question, just because I'm in the correlative science
group. What would you say would be the next big step for
CCSU with maybe this
trial?
I don't know. We can talk about that offline.
Okay.
Thank you, Anne Marie.
Last question.
Yes, Andreas Poser, Medicine. So did you measure the GD2 binding
protein, and did it have any impact on it?
The GD2 binding protein?
Yeah.
No, we did not measure that. What do you mean? The antibody?
No, the naturally occurring one.
No. We haven't done that. That sounds like it could be interesting.
Thanks.
Maybe we could talk about that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
All right.
Fantastic talks so far.
Our next talk is entitled "Precision Targeted Engineering of
CAR T Cells,"
Phil Darcy from Peter McCallum.
Dr. Darcy.
It's an honor to be here, and I'd just like to thank you for the
invitation to present some of our work.
Today, I'm going to talk about our work involving targeted engineering of CAR
T cells by CRISPR editing to
enhance payload delivery, specifically at the tumor site.
These are my disclosures.
So as we've heard so far, engineering T cells with chimeric
antigen receptors is an innovative way to redirect T cells
to cancer cells. And of course, this has shown remarkable effects in
some hematological cancers. However, for solid cancers, this
hasn't been the case, and we've yet to replicate those effects.
And this is due to the suppressive tumor microenvironment,
tumor antigen heterogeneity, and we need to
overcome the lack of trafficking and persistence of the CAR T cells.
We believe one promising approach to do this is through the use of armored CAR T
cells secreting pro-inflammatory cytokines.
So, armored T cells, including CAR T cells, have reached the
clinic. This includes using T cells
expressing IL-12 under the control of an NFAT inducible promoter.
On the left-hand side, you can see in pre-clinical studies,
they've shown inducible iIL-12 expression upon
T cell activation at the tumor site.
Yet in
the clinic, this has resulted in systemic
toxicities.So we believe we
can improve the safety of armored CAR
T cells and increase the tumor-specific transgene
expression by CRISPR knock-in.
So in collaboration with Matt Porteus's lab at Stanford,
we've used CRISPR HDR knock-in
to generate armored CAR T cells.
And this approach involves site-specific
transgene integration, as shown here,
where we
insert the armoring gene into a tumor-specific gene, as shown
here.
And this approach uses a homologous repair template
delivered by an AAV6 vector, and this
really precisely and accurately repairs double-strand breaks.
So through this process, the armoring gene, which has replaced the
tumor-specific gene,
is controlled by an endogenous tumor-specific promoter, and this results in
tumor-specific transgene expression.
And
also, we have disruption of the inhibitory gene that we've replaced.
And so in this process, hopefully,
we can actually increase CAR T cell activity.
So in your standard CAR T cells then,
when the CAR T cell becomes activated after binding antigen, you
get this inhibitory target gene that's been replaced.
Generally, this inhibitory target gene is turned on, resulting in reduced activity
of the CAR T cell. In our CRISPR-engineered armored CAR T cells, the
armoring gene is turned on instead, resulting in pro-inflammatory
cytokine release, and as I said, the inhibitory target gene is
disrupted.
So Amanda Chen in the lab,
we identified tumor-specific target genes that we could use for our CRISPR
knock-in approach. And she did this bulk RNA-seq
analysis in both our mouse anti-HER2 CAR T
cell model and also in our human anti-LewisY CAR T cell model.
So in this experiment, she transferred her mouse or
human CAR T cells into tumor-bearing mice
and then sorted out the CAR T cells and performed bulk RNA-seq analysis.
The results are shown here in this slide on the right-hand side.
We can see a range of different target genes that were
upregulated in the tumor
in contrast to the spleen, and this included, of course, PD-1 as you would expect,
but there are also
other target genes that more highly expressed in the tumor that we identified.
So we want to evaluate those target genes and whether they were actually better
target genes for our CRISPR knock-in approach.
But we first had to determine whether knocking out or disrupting
those target genes might be detrimental to the CAR T cell, which
we want to avoid, of course.
So, what we did here was we tested eight knockouts of 27
target genes that we identified from our bulk RNA-seq,
examined these genes, knocked out these genes in our human
anti-LewisY CAR T cells, looked at cytokine, cytotoxicity,
cell proliferation, and the memory phenotype.
So in a tariff work that Carmen in the lab
talk,
the 27 target genes are listed across the top there.
And she tested each of these genes and knocked out from these
human CAR T cells and looked at a range of different functions that I've just
mentioned.
And what we were able to
narrow down from the 27 target genes was that we narrowed this down to six
target genes as listed here, PD-1 being one of them.
And this is based on the knockout not adversely affecting
function of those CAR T cells, and they were truly
tumor-specific with a decreased expression in the spleen.
So what we did next was that we assessed
the suitability of each of those target genes, those six target genes for our
CRISPR knock-in approach by knocking in GFP in each of those
genes
by CRISPR knock-in. And we tested this in vivo in
our human CAR T cell model,
bearing established LewisY-positive ovarian tumors.
We dopantly transferred our human CAR T cells, their gene-edited CAR
T cells, and analyzed GFP marker
in the tumor and spleen of those mice.
And what was interesting
was we found that this
gene target, NR4A2,
it was an interesting gene, which we saw high
restricted expression of GFP in the tumor compared to the spleen.
So we suggested that this target gene may be good for
inducing safety of our approach.
Another good target or interesting target was RGS16, which
saw a very high expression in the tumor, although there was expression in the
spleen, it was much higher, and we thought this particular target gene may be good
for inducing more potent effects after CRISPR
knock-in.
In previous studies,
knockout of the
NR4
family or transcription family has limited CAR T cell function, and
RGS16 has also been shown to promote T cell exhaustion.
So disrupting these two genes may actually be advantageous for CAR T cell
activity. So we believe these are two good targets to use.
So what we've so far
revealed
was the two target genes, NR4A2, it's more
tumor-restricted in terms of
its expression, lower expression in tumors, and may be good for
transgenes that have dose-limiting toxicity issues, such as
IL-12.We've identified
RGS16. It's less tumor restricted
than NR4A2, but it's high expression in tumors, and
it may be good for transgenes with more tolerable toxicity
profiles such as IL-2. So we went ahead and tested our approach for each of
those therapeutic target,
pro-inflammatory cytokines.
So we tested IL-12
as a first pro-inflammatory gene.
We did this in our human anti-LewisY CAR T-cell model,
bearing established ovarian tumors expressing LewisY.
In two different donors, we're able to show that adoptive transfer of our
gene-edited CAR T-cells where NR4A2 was driving
IL-12, showed potent anti-tumor effects in both
cases. However, when IL-12 was driven by
RG16 promoter or PD1, we start to see a drop in weight of the
mice and see systemic toxicity. And it's correlated
with IL-12 production in the serum shown here
from those two promoters. So,
NR4A2 was driving a safe delivery of IL-12 to the tumor,
inducing strong anti-tumor effects.
We similarly tested this in our murine anti-HER2 CAR T-cell
model in mice bearing established breast or colon carcinomas expressing
HER2. Again, when we adoptively transferred our mouse CAR
T-cells, gene-edited CAR T-cells, we see strong anti-tumor effects in both
cases, and it's translated to enhanced survival of mice.
In terms of mechanism from IL-12, we found that in both
models, we see an increase in numbers of our gene-edited
CAR T-cells at the tumor site, increased proliferative capacity,
and increased polyfunctionality in terms of gamma and
TNF in both models. And also,
in our immunocompetent model, we also saw activation of
host anti-tumor immunity following transfer of our gene-targeted cells.
We have a tetramer that recognizes P15E antigen on
MC38 tumors. And in this case, we saw increase in
tet positive CD8 cells in the spleen following
treatment with our gene-edited CAR T-cells.
We saw by bulk TCR sequencing,
and
oligo expansion of several TCR clonotypes are shown
here. And in mice that had cleared primary tumor
following treatment with gene-edited CAR T-cells, we rechallenged with the
parental tumor, MC38, and we saw, again, strong
anti-tumor responses showing that these cells could persist,
and also indicated, obviously, activation of host anti-tumor immunity.
We then extended our approach to IL-2, again, in our human
CAR T-cell model, bearing established ovarian tumors.
What was interesting here is when IL-2 was driven by the RG16 promoter,
we saw the strongest anti-tumor effect compared to PD1
or NR4A2. And this indicates that RG16 was producing a lot
more IL-2 at the tumor site inducing effects.
Importantly, it was safe. So IL-2 was much more tolerable than IL-12.
We saw no drop in weight in the mice.
In terms of mechanism, again,
as for IL-12, we saw an increase in proliferative capacity.
Total number of these gene-edited CAR T-cells was
increased, increased polyfunctionality in terms of
cytokine of these gene-edited CAR T-cells.
Now, this is the important experiment.
We compared our knock-in strategy, using
NR4A2, and we put GFP,
again, driven by that promoter. And we
tested the tumor-restricted expression compared to the
NFAT promoter, which, as I said earlier, has caused systemic
toxicity in patients.
So we did this in our
mouse CAR T-cell model in tumor-bearing mice.
We adoptively transferred our mouse CAR T-cells,
where NR4A2 was driving GFP, or where
the inducible promoter, NFAT, was inducing
expression of GFP, and analyzed our
GFP in both tumors and peripheral tissue in mice.
And you can see here when NR4A2 was driving GFP, you see
tumor-restricted expression, as seen here, very low expression
of GFP in peripheral tissue. But with the NFAT inducible system, we see
high expression in the tumor, but also peripheral expression.
And this really underlies the systemic toxicity we see in
patients.
We also compared both promoter systems for IL-12, and you
can see, I hope these work. You see with NR4A2, you
see no toxicity, as I've showed you in vivo in our mouse
models. Yet on
right-hand side, where NFAT inducible promoter was driving IL-12, you
see
quite rapid toxicity in the mice, drop weight quite rapidly
as shown here.
So for clinical applicability,
we've been able to reduce our knocking approach from a two-step
approach down to one step. So our
initial approach involved CRISPR knocking of our armoring transgene followed
by retroviral transduction, as shown here.
We've been able to reduce this to one step now,
and that involved CRISPR knocking of both our armoring gene,
and also our CAR into the TRAC locus.
Importantly, it did not reduce our CAR
expression. In fact, it actually increased our CAR expression when
we knocked into the TRAC locus, and we saw no
drop in GFP expression from our one-step protocol,
as you can see here, after activation of our gene-edited CAR
T-cells.Also, applied our
one-step protocol to the therapeutic genes IL12 and
interleukin-2 as well. You can see in vitro, we
see a good expression of IL12 and IL2 from our one-step
protocol,
the knock-in and in vivo again in our human CAR T cell model, when
we transfer these gene-edited CAR T cells producing IL12 or IL2,
we get good tumor control as we've shown
before.
Now, the last bit of data I really want to
touch upon,
and this is unpublished, this data.
Carmen in the lab
showed a deviation between our knock-in data with GFP and our
RNA-seq data. So you see on the right-hand side here, you recall
earlier our bulk RNA-seq data in human CD8 CAR T
cells in the spleen. This revealed only
low expression of RG16, similarly to
NR4A2 and PD-1, shown here. Yet in our
GFP knock-in data, where
RG16 is driving GFP expression,
again, we saw a high expression in the tumor and
quite high expression in the spleen.
So we're getting peripheral expression through that promoter as in contrast
to NR4A2. And we propose that this
loss of gene regulation may be due to disruption of the
RG16
gene through CRISPR knock-in.
So, we've tried a new knock-in strategy we've developed, where we can preserve
endogenous RG16 expression using a P2A linker, as
shown here, where
the P2A linker is
inserted downstream of GFP. So this actually retains the endogenous
gene expression of RG16 in this case.
You can see now, in our mouse model when we test this new
knock-in strategy,
this P2A linker, now we can actually control
expression at the tumor, GFP expression.
We get very low expression in the
spleen in this case.
So we went ahead and tested this new knock-in strategy,
driving our therapeutic genes, IL12 and IL2.
You can see up the top here,
when we do that, we can see very good tumor control
using this new knock-in strategy with the P2A linker.
And in fact, if we compare it to NRA42 driving
IL12, we actually get-- It drives better tumor control at very low doses of
the gene-edited CAR T-cell that we transferred.
Also, I demonstrated this new knock-in strategy works with
interleukin-2 as well, shown here.
And so, we're showing that this knock-in strategy, this new,
we call it next-generation knock-in strategy, enables a more favorable safety
profile. So again, we tested this in our mouse
CAR T-cell model, bearing established tumors where we transferred
our
CAR T cells, our gene-edited CAR T cells,
where we compared
both knock-in approaches.
And we analyzed GFP in the tumor and peripheral tissues as well.
So in the case where RG16 was disrupted and
we're knocking in GFP, you see high expression in the tumor of GFP,
but also
high expression also in the peripheral tissue, as we showed
before.
In our new knock-in strategy where RG16 is actually intact,
you see high expression in the tumor, again, but we see much
reduced expression in the peripheral tissue.
So we believe this knock-in strategy is a good way and
actually opens up more target genes we can use for our
knock-in approach. And so we're testing those at the moment.
We've gone on to show that it's a 3' untranslated region that actually
confers this enhanced specificity.
I haven't got time to show you that data today, but it's due to the 3'
untranslated region.
So this works under review at the moment.
So, just to really summarize the work I showed you today.
We've identified two tumor-specific genes, NR4A2, which is highly
tumor-restricted. We believe it's good for
inducing safety of our CRISPR knock-in approach.
RG16 is highly expressed in tumors, and
it's ideal for inducing potency. So,
for transgenes that have a better toxicity profile,
we would ideally use this promoter, NR4A2, for
those transgenes that cause
systemic toxicity.
We've shown it works with IL12 and IL2.
We see increase in CAR T cell function,
and also an increase in host anti-tumor immunity.
And we're now testing this for other transgenes of interest, chemokines
such as CXCL9 and 10, to see whether we can actually increase the number of
CAR T cells trafficking to the tumor.
And also a combination of transgenes as well.
So we're very keen to
translate this now into patients at Peter Mac over the next few years.
This leads me to thank the people that
worked on this project, particularly Carmen and Amanda, who
did most of the experiments I showed you today.
I'd like to thank the co-senior authors of this
project, Paul Beavis and Imran Haque.
We'd like to thank our collaboration with Matt Porteus from Stanford,
who helped us
develop the CRISPR HDR technology,
and also I'd like to thank our and acknowledge our funding bodies
for supporting our research. Thank you.
We have time for some questions if people want to come to the mic.
Yes.
I just want to follow up on the importance in autoimmune disease.
I'm actually a nephrologist by training, and I founded a company
doing ex vivo CD19 CARs. We treated five
patients, autoimmune disease, three lupus, two with
scleroderma, and the results are remarkable.
For this audience sake, you can think of them as your worst case
GVHD patient who has failed every single immunosuppressant.
Those are the patients being selected now for these studies.
And the results I've seen, it just blows your mind.
Other questions?
Yes.
That was a great talk, Phil.
Rob Manguso from the Broad and MGH.
I have a question about the specificity for expression.
So when you guys do the experiments to look at tumor expression versus other
tissues, the other factor that's going on there is that in the
experiment you're doing is that the tumor is the site of antigen engagement.
Is that right?
Have you ever looked to see if-- So I'm assuming like NR4A2 is probably driven by
TCR signaling. The RGS16 is it? Is that one
also a TCR inducible gene?
It's
induced by T cell activation, regulating a G protein.
So do you know if T cells are activated in some other peripheral tissue
because of perhaps like off tumor but on target
antigen specificity, do you think that it is likely that these
genes will also turn on in those tissues
even though it's outside the tumor?
Or is there some special other microenvironmental factors that are driving
expression only in the tumor?
Yeah, we believe that in our
mouse immunocompetent model, it's actually a self-antigen model.
So,
HER2 is actually expressed in the breast and the cerebellum
in those mice.
And we
haven't seen activation in those sites
in our immunocompetent model. Of course, we can't test that in our
immunocompromised setting,
so we believe they're
truly tumor specific,
particularly in RA42. RGS16 was expressed in the peripheral
tissue, as I showed you there.
Mm.
So you have to be careful with that.
But I think with our new knocking strategy, I think we believe we've overcome that
by retaining the exogenous gene. So we're not
disrupting it at all.
Mm.
So I think that really opens up possibility of either using other target genes as
well.
Very cool. Thanks.
Go ahead.
Very nice talk. So
RGS16 promoter or the expression
correlates with T cells exhaustion?
Yes.
So then if you use this promoter to express IL12,
would that IL12 kind of suppress
the promoter activity and reduce this IL12 possibly?
That's a good question.
So we still tested that long term in our mouse models,
pre-clinical models.
We're actually seeing
CAR T cell activity when we re-challenge the mice.
So we're getting long term persistence, so they don't seem to be exhausted.
Mm.
So
we're knocking out, in that case, where we're just using a promoter to
drive the armoring gene, we've knocked out, we've disrupted
or inhibited the RGS16 expression.
In the new knocking strategy, though, where we retain expression,
it may be a possibility that that may drive exhaustion.
Yeah. But in theory, this could be like a
negative feedback, so it can be-
Yeah
... advantageous so that you kind of-
Well, that's what we've shown. We've shown that the gene-edited CAR T
cells persist long term
in mouse models. So that's why we believe it's a good approach that we can knock
out these genes that cause either exhaustion or
reduce CAR T-cell function, like NR4A2.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's a dual approach, basically.
Yeah.
Sean Judge from UC Davis Medical Center. A question for Dr. Mackall.
We're very interested in the regional therapy.
We're doing a panel for this.
We're not in panel yet.
We're doing the panel.
We'll do a panel if you don't mind waiting.
We'll just finish questions for this speaker, okay?
But stick around because the panel is coming right away.
Appreciate the enthusiasm.
Really beautiful work. I have a question about the CAR model you're using.
Do you see more background secretion when the CARs are
associated with tonic signaling versus something more benign like a CD19 CAR?
Yeah. We've just used it for
our Lewis Y CAR and HER2 CAR, but we haven't tested it for
other CARs like CD19 yet.
Mm-hmm.
So it's a good question. I think we need to evaluate this against other targets
using other CARs.
Great. Thank you.
Great. Thank you. So we are going to turn to a panel.
We'll try to do it quick and get people out of here.
Before we get you back to the
mic, I have a question that I'd like to pose to the panel.
As a solid tumor oncologist, I'm
particularly intrigued by the notion
of tissue trafficking, and so it's
sort of a joint question. Is the intraventricular administration that we heard
about
from Dr. Mackall model for other treatment paradigms in solid tumors,
and with regards to the knockin strategy that we just heard
about,
can we really exploit chemokines to think about tissue tracking,
and how might we combine those approaches?
This is very future thinking, but I'd love for you guys to speculate.
The trafficking issue is one
that's been very poorly studied. We all say that
T cells has limited trafficking to tumors, but
I don't think we really know that. We haven't pressure tested that.
What we don't know is whether they don't traffic well, or they just don't expand
once they get there.
But I think it sort of stands to reason if you know you've got a
sequestered organ, you're not going to metastasize out of that
space. You can just get more efficiency by
putting the T cells where the tumor is.
I got to say, drug companies hate it.
They want to give things intravenously.
And so I don't think it makes as much sense when you're talking about a disease
that's going to metastasize. If that answers your question.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Well, thank you. And to follow up on that, regarding the work from Dr.
Mackall,
the regional CAR T cells, you
notice that those patients also get peripheral CAR T cells.
Did you notice any phenotypic or functional differences between those
cells that are retained and those that traffic into the periphery?
Yeah, we really don't have the power to answer that.
We've had a really hard time getting our hands on the CSF T
cells. The numbers are just not high enough, and you
can't get enough CNS. So that's why we're relying on single-cell RNA seq,
that we can get. But we can't do flow cytometry, for instance.
So I don't know the answer.
I think there's another question. Go ahead.
Hi. A question for Dr. Gill.
I wanted to ask how you uncouple the in vivo CAR T cell
response from the broad inflammatory kind of adjuvant response you
see
associated with cytokine release.
Do you think that the antiviral response is essential for the
therapeutic outcome, or is it
essentially just a CAR T response?
Well, I think that
what I try to show with the published myeloma data
is that it appears that there is a bimodal
syndrome, if you like, that early on there is an acute, very early, within a
few hours, there's an acute
inflammation. And then that settles down, and then
a few days later, then you have another what is probably
real traditional CRS.
As to whether they're characterized by the same cytokine milieu, they
probably are not, but I think that the studies that have been published
so far, as preliminary as they are, don't have sufficient granularity to tell
us.
And so I suppose on the one hand, you could say if
the acute toxicity was very distinct immunologically
from a T cell activation one, then you might expect there'd be
a different cytokine milieu, and probably you want a
multiplex/many plex cytokine
profile for that. Conversely, if it is,
like I speculate, mostly related to TCR cross-linking, then
it might be more similar to what you see with CAR T cell
activation, CRS.
Can I ask a related question?
Do you think that the CD4, CD8
transduction ratio is important?
Do you think that you could get a similar therapeutic response with one subset over
the other? CD8s associated with less potential for
CRS. Do you think that would be a feasible strategy?
As far as I know,
when people have tried pre-clinically to compare just
with ex vivo, CD8 CAR versus CD4 CAR versus both, that
maybe not surprisingly, you get better activity when you have both.
Mm-hmm.
And I don't think we know about the ratios, though.
Because of T cell proliferation, you actually end up with more
CD8 than CD4 very quickly, even if you infuse a one-to-one
ratio.
Thank you.
From this side.
Hi. Taylor Mills, University Hospital Tubingen.
Kind of a question for the panel and a somewhat philosophical question.
So with the advent of CAR T, it was, "Oh, here's the magic
drug. We can solve cancer. We just put in
the antigen onto the CAR T-cell, and now it works." And obviously, that's not the
story for most cancer types. And now we have things, armored
CAR, in vivo CAR, right? It's still just putting the
pressure on CAR, though, on CAR T, particularly for this panel.
Is that still the future, do you believe, for
cancer therapy? We should continue to just over-engineer the
problem, or do we need to look at the problem
from a different angle?
Well-
10 seconds or so.
Of course, I'd love nothing more than to have combination therapy.
That's been the answer in oncology from the very beginning, except for
anti-PD-1, where they can cure metastatic disease.
So I think the hope springs eternal.
This is a very expensive therapy.
Mm-hmm.
And for it to be worth its salt, it
really does need to be extremely powerful.
And if it is just one component of a multi-agent regimen,
I think it'd be a hard sell. That said, if there was
something you could add with it that would make them a lot more effective, then
let's see it. But so far, people haven't found it.
It's not that they haven't looked. Checkpoint hasn't really worked with CAR Ts.
Yeah. Same kind of problem, right?
The others?
All right. Well, I have a slightly different perspective, which is that
we're still doing mostly CAR Ts. There's
some CAR NKs, some CAR macrophages maybe.
It is theoretically possible. People have tried, but I think it's
worth looking again to all these immune cells come from
originally hematopoietic stem cells.
So it's theoretically possible to actually get a complete immune
systemWhich is antigen-specific with a
single cellular intervention, possibly.
And
it's also possible maybe to hit two with one.
I didn't really highlight this in my talk, but
with the in vivo approach, if you transduce
CD7 positive cells, you get both T and NK cells.
So it could be a case of it's the other white meat, like it's not
sufficiently different and you want something totally different.
But at the very least, I think it's possible.
And to answer your philosophical question with a somewhat philosophical
answer, I think that, clearly, we all know that is how the immune system works with
more than a single effector type. Another aspect of it is
that T cells, while the CAR T cell
platform, with the exception of bispecific or multispecific,
relies on a single
pain point of recognition, vulnerability, I suppose, as
shown with antigen negative relapse.
Actually, T cells are somewhat of a Swiss Army knife, maybe not
the most high-end Swiss Army knife, but they have multiple effective functions, not
just one.
Just also like to add, the
armored CAR T cell approach is one example,
and that's really showing some promise.
We've just seen with IL-15 armored CAR T cells targeting GPC3,
and we're getting some responses in those patients compared to these conventional
CARs. So I think we're learning, and there's fairly recent trials, and I think we
can really use that as a platform to
even further increase the activity of these CAR T cells.
But as I mentioned in today's talk, we have to be able to do that
safely.
So some cytokines, of course, like IL-12, we have to be very careful.
It is a very good potential cytokine to use because it induces that
host anti-tumor effect, and I think that's what we need, I believe what we really
need to do,
to get long-term responses.
So I think the technology is increasing and
expanding, and I think once we can utilize that, we can safely
use approaches like armored CAR T cells much better.
Yeah. Thank you.
Great. With that, I want to thank the three wonderful
speakers for a very informative session.
And thank you all for staying till the end, and I hope you have a very good
evening. Thank you.
Yeah.
If you'll visit answer later.
Mm-hmm.